so was also tue nicht die Zeiten sind
düster wenn es aufgrund des Krieges und
der daraus resultierenden Energiekrise
plötzlich zu Strom Ausfällen zu
Blackouts oder zu anderen Szenarien
kommt ja einer der hat sich schon vor
Beginn der corona-krise einen Vorrat
angelegt der locker für zwei Monate
reicht hier sind die exklusiven Tipps
von prepper Konstantin
Stromausfälle Naturkatastrophen und
Viruserkrankungen Krisensituationen
erleben wir auch in Europa immer
häufiger auf diese und andere Notfälle
sollten wir also immer vorbereitet sein
sagt sogar die Bundesregierung das
Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe empfiehlt Vorräte für
mindestens zwei Wochen jederzeit im Haus
zu haben falls in der ganzen Stadt
plötzlich der Strom ausfällt alle
Supermärkte geschlossen sind oder
Bewohner ihre Wohnungen nicht mehr
verlassen dürfen soll dieser Vorrat sie
über die Runden bringen das ist kein
Vorschlag das ist eine Pflicht
es ist eine rechtliche es sei zwar
Empfehlung aber ich sehe das als Pflicht
wenn sogar der Staat also der für dich
verantwortliche sagt du hör mal es kann
sein dass ich dich 14 Tage lang nicht
versorgen kann seid aber vorbereitet
prapper Konstantin hat sich schon vor
Beginn der corona-krise mit einem Vorrat
ausgestattet der locker für zwei Monate
reicht falls eine Krise ausbricht kann
er sich mehrere Wochen lang selbst
versorgen ohne das Haus verlassen zu
müssen doch was gehört alles in einen
sinnvollen krisenvorrat Nummer eins
Lebensmittel im Vorrat sollten Essen und
Trinken für mindestens zehn Tage
enthalten sein wichtig dabei eine
erwachsene Person benötigt etwa zwei
Liter Flüssigkeit pro Tag bei einem
10-tage-vorrat sollten also 20 Liter pro
Person da sein das Essen sollte gut
verträglich und haltbar sein im
Idealfall kann eine Person pro Tag 2200
Kilokalorien zu sich nehmen
grundsätzlich gibt es keine richtige
feste Regel was du brauchst so
hauptsache du hast ganz viel zu futtern
ganz viel zu essen damit du eine Weile
über die Runden kommst
langfristig habe ich für mich
festgestellt es ist wichtig eine Auswahl
zu haben um die Moral wiederum zu
stärken braucht man viel Abwechslung
Nummer zwei Hausapotheke Medizin
Verbandskasten und Hygieneartikel
sollten ebenfalls vorrätig sein
Fieberthermometer Pinzette
Einweghandschuhe und Atemschutzmasken
sind ebenfalls sinnvoll medizinische
Vorsorge braucht man auch und falls was
sein sollte will man nicht erst zur
Apotheke laufen müssen denn wenn
irgendeine Krise stattfindet haben wir
bei Corona ja festgestellt dann laufen
sie alle zu den Apotheken dann wenn es
schon zu spät ist Nummer 3 das Nötigste
für den Stromausfall Taschenlampen
Kerzen Streichhölzer und campinglampen
als Lichtquelle Batterien Akkus und
powerbanks um elektronische Geräte
benutzen zu können und ein Campingkocher
um das Essen warm zu machen
Nummer 4 wichtige Dokumente Pässe
Führerscheine und familienurkunden
sollten im Original oder als Kopie in
einem Mappe abgeheftet und sicher
aufbewahrt werden auch Testamente
Wertpapiere und Zeugnisse sollten sicher
verwahrt und in einem Krisenfall
jederzeit mitgeführt werden natürlich
besteht keine gesetzliche Pflicht zur
Vorsorge doch es kann immer zur
Situationen kommen in denen der Staat
seine Bürger nicht mehr versorgen kann
und jeder sich selbst helfen muss
solange man die Mittel und Möglichkeiten
dazu hat soll man im Voraus vorbereiten
bei 81 Millionen Einwohnern wenn auch
nur ein Drittel prepper ist und
vorbereitet ist und es gibt eine Krise
dann brauchen sich die staatlichen
Institutionen wie die Polizei Feuerwehr
THW und Co brauchen sich um dieses eine
Drittel nicht zu kümmern das heißt die
Kräfte die helfen sollen können darauf
fokussiert werden denen dem geholfen
werden muss
also jeder der ein bisschen vorsorgt
entlastet das gesamte System in einer
Krise
[Musik]